hallöchen freuen und herzlich willkommen
zu einem etwas zusammen mit dem troll
könig komme hde wobei kreft freunde main
hall und wir uns gedacht wir nehmen
diese kleine folge auch weil gerade an
diesem tag auch bei comedy folge capcom
vorhersagt dass heute abend ein
livestream ist
die
und das nähre dazu kannst du einmal ganz
kurz sagen dass nähere dazu und zwar
morgen am mittwoch um 16 uhr findet ein
live stream statt und wir wollen
eigentlich praktisch captain spielen
bevor noch gefragt wird was wollt ihr
spielen
cap tief ist so der hauptstand punkt da
wir gemerkt haben jetzt ist eigentlich
die perfekte zeitpunkt gekommen
für ein live stream wir haben uns halt
schon damals immer mal gedacht und auch
die vorstellung stücke ich brauche
schnell bronze stehen die mitte gold
oder schlägen geschmissen
wir haben es halt auch damals immer
schon so gedacht ja fand man sollen wir
dann eigentlich mal leistung machen habt
ihr bock auf den livestream die stars
blabla und allem 1 im live-stream voll
geil macht den x
und wir haben halt immer so gedacht wir
machen den film erst wenn wir wirklich
kein ansporn mehr so richtig haben als
wenn wir wir haben wir haben immer noch
richtig bock drauf aber hast du genug
blöcke ich habe genug brücke jetzt
schnell in die mitte wo das gold holte
gold
wir haben zwar noch genug ansporn
allerdings ist halt die sache dass
mittlerweile wir quasi nur noch unten
drin sind und die ganze zeit warten bis
49 clay finden und alles möglich ab 43
gold weg bis zur neuen claim finden et
cetera pp oder wer gedacht kommen das
könne wir einfach mal im livestream
machen das heißt auf der twitter seite
von comedy auch unten verlinkt sät wird
am mittwoch wenn ihr diese folge gerade
seht also morgen
okay die was kannst du dir davon rüstung
rüstung vom form von gold nicht um
bronze wie soll ich das geld nehmen da
kann ich ein bisschen revanche so macht
man nur einmal noch eben schnell sonst
werd das kann sich mit browns gar nicht
holen alter ich habe dann eben kurzen
stopp so ich war mal wieder vor
genau wir brauchen ganz viel gold erst
mal die menschen diskriminieren perfekt
ja wir haben uns auf jeden fall gedacht
am mittwoch um welche uhrzeit um 16 uhr
machen wir es noch um 16 uhr also vom
termin her einfach morgen oder der 27
im kalender haben wir uns gedacht komm
wir machen einfach man live stream mit
ein paar sachen wo ihr alle dabei sein
könnt ihr links von gomez wie schon
mehrmals gemacht in der beschreibung das
heißt ihr könnt uns da fragen stellen
wir können uns auch was wir hoffen tipps
geben hasse gold ich bin gerade bei team
blau
wir können uns auch tipps geben das ist
was ich am meisten darauf hoffe also
irgendwie wenn ihr wisst okay ihr kriegt
besser leben indem er das und das macht
oder dies und dies oder blah blah blah
dann kann man mit ihm rot ja ich war
gerade bei den blau ich bin fast tot
aber okay eingreifen wieder das machen
ich habe das spiel angekickt von timot
war ans bett abgedreht schnell hoch zu
denen ich hab keine spitzhacke egal als
bett kaum noch unabhängige team laura
kaputt tim roth wurde vernichtet und
okay wir sind noch mit team blau ich
sagte wenn wir beide hier richtig rein
und dann kriegen wir eine schnelle runde
hin
ich habe viel gold das heißt du kriegst
auch leise schwert bogen wie du möchtest
und guckt die haben ja die haben schon
mal zurück das bringt ihn auch jetzt hat
keiner gern mit ich mach das mal ganz
kurz regenerieren
also um zusammen fast live stream am
mittwoch um 16 uhr schaltet eine links
in der beschreibung und da könnt ihr uns
mit ihrem kontakt treten und bla bla bla
und alles wäre erfahrt ihr dann halt im
livestream ende dabei sein kann ist gold
geben ich bin einfach sauer in die mitte
obwohl ja nimmt nur das gold warte mal
wo bist du denn ich habe hier noch einen
gold passt darauf lässt sich nicht
abschließend übte der schießt ihn ja ab
lenkte sie ab hast du das goldmädchen
geworfen habe ich nicht habe ich noch
werfen wir verhehlen
das sind acht stücke bringen wir mal
davon bogen mit 300 an und lenkt ihn ab
irgendwie okay okay ich laufe ich laufe
ich laufe ich hoffe ich falle nicht
unter allein vor ort erschießt auf dich
geschafft hat es geschafft bringen den
bogen am besten mit ok also kaufte ihr
ein schwert liegt einfach in den
schwerter bereich das gehalt dann
bekommst du ein eisen schwert erwarte
ich habe schon einen bogen für dich
verdammt jetzt bin ich auch gestorben
aber leider kein schwert mehr aber egal
bin mir jetzt bei dir gerade so bleibt
man stehen da hast du einen bogen und
den fall
danke anke der liegt allerdings von dir
okay nicht wieder in den kampf da hinten
der hatten bogen bettenburgen das ist
ekelhaft was ich mache ich mal kurz die
mauer hast du schwert du hast ja
natürlich dann bei ihm zwei treffer
eine so einfach ist es ja auch nicht
wir müssen auf jeden fall dafür soll das
die nicht so lange damit zu bleiben okay
noch ein treffer doch ein treffer jetzt
zieht er sich den weg ja er ist noch
immer mit sich aber wir dürfen jetzt
können jetzt vor raschen du kannst einem
schwert rein ich gehe mal nicht mehr da
habe ich gedacht dass wir jetzt eben
haben den effekt dass ihm kein schwert
mehr wird dem kind schwer hatten wir ja
wohl ich habe wieder ich habe wieder ein
bisschen gold geholt damit halt echt
gedacht das leben stellen runde einfach
durch raschen sogar sind machen machen
wir auch gerade schon von vier teams
leben nur noch wir also unser team das
vom gegner team krass ich bräuchte
vielleicht noch ein paar blöcke wenn ich
meine spitzhacke egal die runde läuft
als fünf minuten wir noch zeit sollte
solch mal durch waschen die hand bogen
gemacht wurde alte tier mir noch einen
bogen von wo bekommen die ihre bögen
immer kommen wir noch mal eben das gold
mit was ihr gespannt ist ich würde am
besten der darsteller lauf zu team rot
zur base von timo urteil kann die nicht
entschließen wir unsere branche macht
ist natürlich relativ offen er keiner
hat bisher in gießen geholt nur keiner
weil da wird auch nicht darin offenbar
bis jetzt so roth ich investiere das mal
ganz kurz
ich mache mir auch eben bogen nach erst
das sehr gut 123 so einen bogen und
pfeile
so erfahre und sagt ich brauche ein
schrank alt aber dafür brauche ich auch
die tränke sind nicht wichtig
schnelligkeit um eben rüber zu raschen
medium noch im bogen jetzt kauft erstmal
einen bogen und erschwerten danach ganz
seine eventuelle an trank denke ich
brauche auch noch später nur gold übrig
hast den kopf verlieren aber ich habe
jetzt einen bogen hat mir eine spitze
geholt ich hab jetzt ein schweres leicht
darüber
so jetzt komme ich erst eine spitzhacke
hier ist auch schon wieder richtig viel
gold gesponnen
ja das brauche ich gib mir das am besten
noch mal ich schmeiße dass man eben hin
bleibt einfach da wo du bist dann
schmeißt er das inventar
so bleibt man genau da ich habe acht
stück für dich und kaum noch was noch
was hier ist noch eins so dass auch noch
was sondern würde ich vorschlagen
verteidige du du mal bitte eben kurz die
mitte ja mach ich ja mal zu rot
ich habe auch mal ein paar blocks noch
geholt perfekt 13 gault millau lulu das
geht ab sonntag gefallen euch lebt noch
ich wollte zum coolen weg großer baum im
coolen weko in einen coolen weg für die
coolen
das wäre sonst ein bisschen geschützt
mal sind soll ich mir ein stück getränk
kaufen der haut richtig trinken bringen
nichts bekomme ja macht wohl den stärke
tagen das vielleicht ganz geil so viel
gold wie jetzt haben wir mitte für uns
ja da haben wir waren nicht mehr so viel
gold ja dass er egal und ich kann nicht
wie ich schon so oder so verpackt und
ich kaufe zwei änderte die ich einmal zu
themen also die eine stelle zudem rot
und die andere in die mitte
dann können wir einfach sowas gold hin
und her transportieren okay sie wirklich
hier
wir bauen hier und jetzt quasi immer
mehr aus den augen
also passt auf wo steht diana jazz die
steht wo bist du da bist du was ich habe
power alter ich bin schon begeistert
hier was post sind und schon wieder 50
ist gold tja das ist echt das geld zu
einfach es geht so einfach mal sind die
gegner
du hast komme im team mit amore du nu
ich habe dass er das bett abgebaute
klappt es ja auch schon bald abgebaut so
cook jetzt darüber zu mir wieder was
machst du hier ganz normal bonn mit burg
ist das ehrlich kann man von hier so ein
bisschen jetzt auf jeden fall schon mal
näher an die wollen unbedingt gold haben
wenn wir die mit dem bogen töten da da
richtig verloren
ich glaube ich trinke dem stärke trank
der bereits drei mal einfach drei
minuten branche weiter überraschen er
gleich jetzt können wir über
wahrscheinlich
du kannst loslegen ok jetzt braucht man
da sie links ab genauer perfekt gemacht
erst tod ein starkes herz und jetzt
komme ich auch nochmal mit mad about
erst abgebaut jetzt mal nen bogen
hinterher ich mache das schon verdammt
nicht dass sie auf ok das unter gefallen
und der andere wartet wartet der der den
den schießt mir erst mal schön ab wenn
er bei uns rüber läuft der ist
eingespielt davon der kommt nicht raus
tut ihm mit der hand
freiwillig unter autobauer haben wir
also noch mal live stream termin et
cetera steht alles in der beschreibung
der link auch tatsächlich sagen wir
etwas wollt gibt es uns mit mg zeigt es
mit einem daumen hoch gibt und sie
hoffentlich im livestream morgen wieder
rein machst gut und schön